oh they can't exclusive you've had your
trial tribulations a lot of artists in
the game and I feel like it hasn't
really it really hasn't been any I feel
like the last real beef and hip hop that
people were excited for that there were
records dropping was with you and John
ever since then I feel like it's been
like a whole since YouTube stuff it's
not actual hip-hop like see that was
some real beef yeah hip hop is is Drake
in common right bit yeah you don't
really feel like anything's nothing
Bad's gonna happen it's just Records but
a lot of times but you don't see it
split off into the street it was just
simply with hip hop that's what's up man
you know for artists this is the attempt
to move up at that point and do so if
you make records if you consistently I
thought I artists are going up and down
the same southern base markets and not
going international doing anything
different they don't even know what the
[__] you're talking about
you go out country talking playing those
music that song it's all good live radio
live radio Las Vegas see this with XM
and another thing nowadays man you were
the first artist that really to me
embrace the whole visuals dropping
videos for every song you know the king
you are the to me that they will always
be the king of mixtapes you know what I
mean I don't know what it is today today
nowadays oh man it seems like
everybody's kind of kind of you know
doing that everyone's dropping a video
for every record they put out expire it
the more that's effective do it you're
supposed to I mean I think now the
general public will meet a new artist
before the record company does that's
how it is man cuz you got look on
smaller cameras HD quality yep
so right now if artists are standing
here rapping in front of this he got a
clip for you too indeed you know so and
if you get a man hits based on how his
performance was all people like it
people people mess with it as far as New
York hip hop is concerned of course when
I was coming up as a kid there's always
a talk of who was the king
New York as long as you or home when I
was you know when I was in high school
it was in New Jersey that's everybody
would talk about this day today who
would you consider to be the king and
Wyatt I don't know I mean do you feel
like that there's a I don't feel like
there's really anybody that's really I
mean you could say jay-z but I really
don't think Jays even embrace would
embrace that title I mean I mean really
there's really the biggest rapper out of
New York at the moment this buzzing is
Nicki Minaj really if you think about it
and you think Nikki's the king no not at
all
let's not get it twisted I do not mess
with her music nah-ha I got in trouble
because I don't like her music but is
there anybody who you think could be
coming up I mean I know ASAP Rocky is
out of Harlem he's yeah I mean all of
them I like all those are new guys you
don't you know they could work harder
though see I'm saying like this even
when they get in is it feel like I guess
they feel like they've made it like when
we're not every time I sign the record
day you know what it was
what there's the opportunity to make it
people think once they get that do ya
because so many artists are trying to
actually get a deal when they get the
deal to go I made it and that's not it
what you after is being successful as an
artist right right right
entrance UV um another thing man um you
know I'm a real underground hip-hop dude
and when you sign like mo p and mob deep
I really I was super stoked recently
there's like a little rumored situation
with mob deep
what do you have you have you spoken
with those guys to her they still yeah
we're still cool with I haven't spoken
to him cuz I've been doing I'm busy
movies man 50 who changes phone number
oh you you know in a heartbeat buddy
keep farting lot of cricket phones oh he
got burned pcs oh you treat you like
he's still selling dope
oh that's what's up hey I appreciate you
coming through hopefully the new album
will be dropping in July yeah ii got a
single yet the first single I'm gonna
drop some but I got what's the name
again the gangsta grillz to be out on
the 15th okay and come party with us
we're gonna be ray Knight that's right
the pong honey tea it's going down
hey you you thrown down any money on the
fight sometimes people were like they
just come through and they make you feel
like thanks for inspiring me this will
put out my he pulled out my whole life
life earnings and never bring your girl
around them cuz they be you know that
you like baby we ain't got it like that
right now you know I just I noticed you
your tattoos you're removing the tats
yeah yeah I've been doing that been gone
you just hurts don't it do man
that's the worst yeah you don't get them
if you get them keep them what's up
movie wise man what's on deck because
you are you were dropping movies left
and right I'm a Netflix king over here I
got five movies that haven't released
okay you don't someone's too long yeah
the last project I just wrapped was me
Stallone Schwarzenegger and as a fan I'd
like I'd like to tell you I'd love
another g-unit album and a wouldnt be
mad at unit radios came back because I
was checking for those all the damn time
yeah yeah I think it's time for
something new do I think it's time for
you just erotic game right you know your
kid kid from New Orleans is are you
still is
I had a tweet come in because I asked
people to answer their Twitter question
someone asked is Lloyd Banks so wrong
with the team yeah I mean like you
hesitated a little is he still g-unit or
is there I mean if you ain't Gina what
is it I guess what you know mass if you
don't know a message here nothing okay
so what i point out is like i'd like
when people ask me questions i got to
think before i answer because there's so
many people that pays me yeah you know
like and you've had previous artists to
be around
a they were dealt with inappropriately
when the reason why Gina was dropped so
the general public understand this the
reason why jr. was dropped from
Interscope Records this was the deal I
gave them was so well put together for
them that they were to receive seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
advance on their next album each one of
the artists a word so they got to remove
that within the climate of record
business right now just can't afford it
so it's a cool just let me take mine
over here yeah and I do it when I'm
ready one at a time makes sense is there
any chance ever that you and game will
ever reunite man because there's I
always hear he's a bipolar dude oh he'll
always say one thing and then the next
it's just it's always you he gets asked
about you a lot I'm sure you get asked
about him a lot but it's just always
nobody well what do you think like I
think if you're ever united cuz the
documentary was so crazy under any
circumstances could you ever see y'all
doing one joint together anything like
that or at least just just having a talk
I don't know I just
look let me yeah you when you said that
record was so crazy you're making
reference to things that I've wrote of
course that record it was an amazing
record man right so now meaning the
first three singles off of that four
things that I wrote and D man so now
when you look at that and then you look
at all the disrespect it was displayed
so years years and years and years say
actually self would you be in a hereo
comfortable with the concept of
associating yourself again with someone
who now you don't even know where it
came from
nah here you what inspired it like if I
if I know an issue if I did something
cuz I look I do I do things yeah you do
yes you do so if I did something wrong
that's a Rick Ross my mama I didn't
accept it did I create a motivation for
it right but if I didn't do anything at
all and it
turns into what that turns it's well
yeah it's like bringing a snake back to
life you know you were sick outside that
snake gonna bite you again a person that
doesn't like you from across the street
I hear you don't know you nothing about
you just don't like you well from from a
fan's perspective if that ever happened
five years from now ten years from now
it I think y'all y'all would really
shake up hip hop again yeah I think so
man just from a fan's perspective I'm a
fan of I'm a fan of the game I'm a fan
of you you know anything lately
impressive from the game yeah I really
haven't heard much I mean his album was
cool check about money team tomorrow
Sunday night a train yeah yeah what's
going down man come check me out and be
a club brain 50 I need some of these
headphones man I got these Luda joints
and a problem I haven't seen you so
DePalma be at the Palms this club man
y'all Sunday Kevin Hart's gonna be there
yeah that's right Kevin I'm forgetting
you people ain't gonna be F say keep Ray
J in order this fight night I'm gonna be
we're gonna have a ball out there man
okay cool it's gonna be everybody gonna
be in town cause they're coming fortify
as it is and following that you know we
don't be a club Ryan at the Palms
gangsta grillz mixtape everyone is going
crazy over this to change joint if you
only heard it madness bananas the riot
remakes fifties back it's going down
he's in Vegas Sunday night Mike P in the
building make sure y'all get the DVD
Things Fall Apart oh you got to go pick
that up that's a class laughing I got
the best response from views from now on
perform yeah I've never put a movie out
and then watched it later and you
thought to yourself it could have been
better
no yeah yeah like I think there's not
not the entire film but a particular
area in the film did I feel like it's
like it's maybe slow got the Netflix
classics though yeah you be going
through a Netflix at 2:00 in the morning
like
these in every movie on Netflix show you
knows no look at this the movie business
is it straight to DVD business it is
aren't in business don't know that they
just watch the theater if you think your
major film company see how many releases
they have that actually go straight to
DVD versus how many they actually put
right it is indeed you know so it's a
lot of money then people don't
understand it but again maybe they're
not supposed to understand roll is
rolling in right on time everybody good
and I get a chance to you know explore
my new passion for film I'm not mad when
you relax what do you do i watch movies
or play video games work or my fantasy
football basketball at times people play
that fantasy football turning the
television down and played music from a
different source right yeah his music
and film so when I you know I'm so
conditioned for music that I go to film
for relaxation and I I've been bit by
that book hey man thank you for the time
and you're a legend you know I'm a big
fan and his ribs really prayer I'm
really looking forward to the new music
manga but Sonia name laughter the hair
very quick my name sling and mixtapes at
the swap meet when I was in high school
and you made me a lot of money I was
slinging them JUnit radios like
clockwork anyway I never got anybody
bootlegging my material hey I needed
them to it that was kind of the blog's
back because they didn't know but when
you think about the mixtape circuit it
was a negative thing the established
artists would hate the actual
bootleggers bootleg in the material but
when you can generate enough interest to
be bootleg and I think I really actually
had something on sale back then that was
how people found out about you because
they'll check your bootleg out first and
if they mess with it they go copy again
nowadays that is going there's going
website - yeah Dave man without even
having a CD on sale and then I was like
I was running around doing this song for
12000 - Oh crazy 2030 didn't went up my
I was like oh we got all day
it was no you know sunday rain thanks
for coming through 50 I appreciate your
time it's all good